Зараз пацієнтів майже немає, може, я зайду?
Ні, не можна?
З самого ранку до реєстратури Ірпінської центральної
міської лікарні вишиковується черга.
Безкоштовно консультації профільних спеціалістів, аналізи й обстеження
тепер тут отримують тільки ті, хто має електронне направлення від сімейного лікаря.
Решта пацієнтів має оплатити послуги самостійно.
Так передбачає другий етап медичної реформи в Україні.
На практиці розібратися, за що саме платить держава
та який алгоритм отримання вторинної допомоги не просто.
Вони кажуть, що безкоштовно, а я заплатив 268 гривень.
Отут мені сказали, що безкоштовно отримаю біохімію крові.
А як воно буде? Я знаю?
Не працював комп’ютер, збої, збої, збої.
Це дуже незручно.
Дуже довго поки отримала цей папір.
Безкоштовну стаціонарну, амбулаторну, екстрену, паліативну допомогу
та реабілітацію з 1 квітня цього року мали би отримувати всі українці.
Це передбачає програма медичних гарантій у рамках медреформи.
Аби нею скористатися, пацієнти мають отримати електронне направлення
від сімейного лікаря на консультацію профільних спеціалістів.
Ті за потреби відправляють хворих на додаткові аналізи чи обстеження.
Медзаклад для діагностики і лікування кожен може обирати самостійно серед тих,
що уклали договір на надання послуг з Національною службою здоров’я.
Саме вона компенсує лікарням вартість послуг, наданих пацієнтам у рамках 27 різних пакетів.
Однак подвійну вигоду - оплату від НСЗУ та гроші з гаманця хворого
деякі медичні заклади намагаються отримати й досі.
Пацієнтці Анні Дудкіній спершу відмовили всі 6 медичних установ,
які мають контракт з НСЗУ на проведення комп'ютерної томографії у Києві.
Жінка три місяці виборювала право
пройти рекомендоване лікарем обстеження безкоштовно.
Взагалі були такі відмовки, що в нас, мовляв,
дуже старий апарат, він часто ламається, нам ледь вистачає на те,
щоб обслуговувати наших стаціонарних хворих.
Також була в досить відомій лікарні Києва відмовка:
ми можемо зробити вам КТ, але контраст Ви маєте купити,
але ще ви маєте поставити собі катетер для введення цього контрасту.
Я наприклад завжди працювала офіційно,
були відрахування з моєї зарплати,
то чому, коли я отримала діагноз, не маю
можливості пройти хоч щось безкоштовно?
Обстеження, за яке боролася Анна, зазвичай коштує понад 3 тисячі гривень.
Лікар-онколог рекомендує жінці проходити його двічі на рік.
Цього разу домогтися надання гарантованої послуги Анна змогла
тільки після регулярних дзвінків у медичні установи
та численних скарг на відмови до НСЗУ.
На її думку, реформа реалізується з такими труднощами через дві основні причини –
необізнаність пацієнтів та лікарів, а також звичку самих українців
класти гроші до кишень медиків.
Мені дали направлення на аналізи на гормони.
Сімейна лікарка виписала.
Але де здати цей аналіз, я не можу з'ясувати.
Ні на гарячій лінії НСЗУ, ні моя сімейна лікарка також не знає.
І в нас просто ще люди такі, вони звикли платити.
І їм здається, що якщо вони заплатять, то до них буде якесь інше ставлення.
А якщо не заплатять, то буде гірше ставлення.
Випадок Анни далеко не унікальний.
Операційна директорка одного з благодійних фондів,
що працює з різними категоріями пацієнтів,
розповідає про регулярні звернення людей, від яких вимагають гроші заклади,
що саботують медичну реформу.
Пацієнт може прийти і не знати взагалі, що є послуга безкоштовна.
І йому про це ніхто не повідомить, просто йому виставлять тариф.
Потім є варіанти, коли починають пацієнта обстежувати,
і вже в процесі обстеження кажуть: ну, а тут за КТ стільки-то заплати,
за контраст стільки-то заплати, за інше обстеження стільки-то.
Ми консультуємо таких пацієнтів.
Вони доходять до головних лікарів з такими скаргами,
і лікарі можуть сказати, що це був благодійний внесок.
Якщо ви його не хочете платити, ми вам повернемо гроші.
І бувають прецеденти, коли повертають гроші.
Найчастіше гроші за гарантовані державою послуги вимагають з онкохворих,
особливо коли йдеться про дорогі хімію чи променеву терапію.
Трапляється, що пацієнтів змушують платити ще й за операції та лікарські засоби,
вартість яких НСЗУ відшкодувала медичним установам.
Понад 300 подібних скарг з різних регіонів України
вже надійшло до Національної служби здоров’я.
Як пацієнту зрозуміти, чи мають йому надати цю послугу безплатно
чи не мають надати цю послугу безплатно?
По-перше, на сайті НСЗУ є кілька дешбордів,
які ілюструють заклади, які уклали з нами контракт,
і перелік, на який ця лікарня законтрактована і відповідно,
яку послугу пацієнт може отримати безоплатно.
Якщо складно скористатися сайтом, то в нас є контакт-центр.
Безкоштовний номер для наших пацієнтів 16-77.
Для медичних установ, що підписали контракт с НСЗУ,
але продовжують вимагати гроші у пацієнтів, що мають електронне направлення,
це загрожує припиненням фінансування чи навіть кримінальною справою..
Правоохоронні органи вже розслідують 18 таких випадків.
А поки пацієнти скаржаться на побори, лікарні незадоволені високими вимогами
до медзакладів та занадто низькими тарифами, встановленими державою
за консультації та діагностичні процедури.
Головний лікар Ірпінської центральної міської лікарні каже,
що закладу вдається вижити без скорочень персоналу
тільки завдяки обслуговуванню майже 600 тисяч пацієнтів на рік,
доплата за лікування коронавірусу та фінансуванню з місцевого бюджету.
У нас з’явилася конкуренція, ми почали боротися за пацієнта.
Ми почали боротися за якість медичних послуг, але при цьому
ми зіштовхнулися з проблемою, що інколи тарифи не покривають вартості процесу.
Ми б могли надавати більший об’єм медичних послуг,
але вимоги до цих послуг були прописані Національною службою здоров’я
настільки, як-то кажуть, жорсткі, що ми,
навіть маючи змогу і надаючи зараз першу допомогу при інфаркті і при інсульті,
ми не можемо розраховувати на компенсацію від держави за цим пакетом.
Щорічне всеукраїнське дослідження Індексу здоров’я показало,
що в 2019 більше половини українців
платили за амбулаторну чи стаціонарну допомогу з власної кишені.
Якщо другий етап медичний реформи вдасться втілити,
переборовши спротив деяких медичних закладів та необізнаність пацієнтів,
держава зможе повністю покривати видатки українців на основні медичні послуги.
Однак на це можуть піти роки.